das ist eine geschichte über kleidung
über die kleidung die wir tragen über
die menschen die diese kleidung
herstellen und über die auswirkungen die
das alles auf unseren planeten hat das
ist eine geschichte über gier und angst
gemacht und armut
es ist sehr komplex weil es sich über
die ganze welt erstreckt aber es ist
auch ganz einfach weil es unsere
verbindung zu den menschen auf zeigt die
mit herz und händen hinter dem ganzen
stehen
[Musik]
ich trieb in diese geschichte hinein
ohne einen funken ahnung über mode und
fing mit ein paar ganz einfachen fragen
an
was ich jedoch herausfand hat mein
denken über die kleidung die ich trage
für immer verändert und ich hoffe dass
es das gleiche bei dir bewirkt
[Musik]
am besten du beginnst mit deinem namen
und erzählt mir alles anfing
ich heiße luft segel und ich bin
journalistin und moderatorin aus
großbritannien
und ich bin seit über zehn jahren
förmlich besessen von den
umweltpolitischen und sozialen
auswirkungen der modeindustrie
ich liebe kleidung einfach ich liebe
alles an ihr die poesie den spaß die
farben das gewebe sie sind unsere zwei
drei jahre dauert es im scan ich hatte
natürlich auch den klassischen riesigen
kleiderschrank und beinahe täglich
stifter ich ihn mit immer neuen taschen
und klamotten voll und trotzdem hatte
ich nie etwas zum anziehen
wie konnte ich ein passendes outfit
zusammenstellen wir kommunizieren unsere
identität teilweise über unsere kleidung
ist das ist geschichtlich gesehen nichts
neues es gibt ja die trends am hofe und
marie antoinette mit ihren riesigen
hüten
es war schon immer eine sehr persönliche
kommunikation in vielerlei hinsicht und
genau das interessiert mich besonders
daran nämlich dass es ein fundamentaler
teil davon ist was wir über uns zu
kommunizieren wünschen
in der mode entwickelte sich eine art
modenschau system mit den vier
jahreszeiten wie in der natur und lange
zeit lief es auch erstaunlich präzise
wie ein uhrwerk
doch heute kann man das getrost aus dem
fenster werfen denn es hat überhaupt
nichts mehr mit der heutigen mode
industrie zu tun
heute gelten völlig neue regeln nt
geschäft es nur wenn der fokus
verschiebt sich auf skrupellose weise
von der chefin in eine richtung die
eigentlich nur noch großen
geschäftsinteressen dient lux after
business and just als teenager machte
ich mir eigentlich nur gedanken über den
preis der klamotten die ich kaufte
entweder traf ich meine wahl nach
schnitt oder gutem angebot
rückblickend bemerkte ich aber das lange
zeit die meiste kleidung hier in amerika
produziert worden war in den 60ern
stellten wir immer noch 95 prozent
unserer kleidung selbst her
heute sind es nur noch etwa drei prozent
und die anderen 97 prozent werden den
sämtliche entwicklungsländer ausgelagert
[Musik]
ich bin seit neun jahren im modegeschäft
wir haben über 25.000 beschäftigte
alleine in der bekleidungsartikel
produktion und wir produzieren 1 von 6
handeln die in den usa verkauft werden
wenn man in einem laden geht und den
richtpreis eines kleidungs artikels mit
dem preis von vor 20 jahren vergleicht
wird man eine preisinflation feststellen
das heißt der preistrend ist
kontinuierlich gesunken doch sind auch
unsere kosten gesunken
ganz sicher nicht im gegenteil sie sind
gestiegen je mehr an produktion
outgesourced wurde desto niedriger wurde
der preis unserer kleidung dabei
entstand ein völlig neues modell namens
fast fashion schnelle mode das praktisch
über nacht die art und weise wie
kleidung gehandelt wurde veränderte
haben ein hektar ist der bisher größte
des unternehmens und gerade mal eine von
vier jahren den ganzen land geplant sind
das ist alles teil an highstreet
evolutionsforscher haben wir jetzt
praktisch 52 saison jetzt jede woche
sehen die etwas neues reinkommt war und
fast das geschaffen damit sie im grunde
nie mehr vertrauen können
[Musik]
diese metallischen fransen dort gibt es
für 39 dollar pro fresh einem brandneuen
laden in der stadt mit preisschildern
die wahrscheinlich noch mehr
preisbewusste käufer ansprechen werden
amerikanische kunden haben die rolle von
h&m in der mode wirklich verstanden und
wir wissen dass amerikanische kunden
sehr wertorientiert wird wenn man diese
beiden zusammen bringt also mehr doch
unter wert da hat man das erfolgsrezept
dieser japanische textileinzelhändler
verzeichnet in den usa einen gewaltigen
erfolg
die preise sind gefällt doch die
herstellungsweise hat sich völlig
verändert
und irgendwann fragt man sich woher das
alles auf der globale markt ist ein ort
an dem wir arbeitsort ihren unter
welchen bedingungen auch immer und
anschließend die produkte zu mir
zurückkommen und zwar billig genug um
sie bedenkenlos wegwerfen zu können die
lokalisierte produktion bedeutet im
endeffekt dass die gesamte herstellung
der güter in niedrig kosten länder
ausgelagert wurde besonders da hin wo
löhne sehr niedrig sind und auch niedrig
gehalten werden
das bedeutet dass diejenigen an der
spitze der wertschöpfungskette
entscheiden können wo die produkte
hergestellt werden
dabei können sie schön hin und her
wechseln wenn zb eine fabrik saag dass
sie es nicht mehr so billig produzieren
können da wie dort die marke tür dann
beauftragende sie eben nicht mehr und
wechsel sein wo wir es billiger kriegen
die läden im westen haben täglich
niedrigpreise das heißt jeden tag werde
ich von denen gedrückt und ich muss
meine arbeiter drücken so läuft das
die läden stehen im ständigen
konkurrenzkampf und wenn sie zu uns
kommen wegen einer bestellung oder einer
verhandeln heißt es der lage xy verkauft
dieses hemd für 5 dollar
also muss ich es für vier dollar
anbieten ihr müsst es billiger
herstellen also machen wir das dann
kommt eine andere marke und sagt hey die
verkaufen es für vier dollar
dann ist unser neuer richtpreis 3 dollar
wenn es auf drei dollar hin krieg kommen
wir ins geschäft ansonsten nicht weil
wir die aufträge so dringend benötigen
und kann andere optionen haben stimmen
wir ihm zu denn im grunde versuchen wir
nicht mehr als zu überleben
so kann es nicht weitergehen
entweder steigt der preis der produkte
oder hersteller müssen schließen
beziehungsweise an allen ecken und enden
ein sparen an allen ecken und enden zu
sparen und sogar sicherheitsvorschriften
zu missachten wurde in diesem neuen
geschäftsmodell zur allgemein
akzeptierten norm
bis eines april morgens ein
schrecklicher vorfall in bangladesch die
schattenseite der modeindustrie auf die
titelseiten brachte die staatlichen
medienberichten zufolge stürzte ein
achtstöckiges gebäude in der nähe von
der k 1
bei den mehr als 70 menschen ums leben
kamen
[Applaus]
rettungskräfte stehen im wettlauf mit
der zeit in den trümmern suchen sie
verzweifelt nach überlebenden
100000 tod hunderte noch lebendig
begraben behörden in bangladesch
berichten dass die fabrik inhaber einer
evakuierungsanordnung retten
etwa 400 tote hunderte werden noch
vermisst
fabrikarbeiter in bangladesch zahlenden
hohen preis billiger kleidung eine
riesige menschenmenge hat sich in der
nähe des gebäudes versammelt unter ihnen
viele familienmitglieder die nach ihren
angehörigen suchen und sie berichten
dass sie noch immer hilfeschreie aus den
von anhören
der friede von ihren lang sein die
hoffen
minute
ich ging von meinem arbeitsplatz in
richtung treppenhaus als sie das
erreichte für das gebäude zusammen und
meine beide wurden eingeklemmt
tanzen noch die seitenwand auf meine
beine klar dass ich meine beine da nicht
mehr raus bekam und gab auf sich
gedanken rasten mir durch den kopf
nicht mal wein konnte ich
[Musik]
anyway jeder der wie ich über die
probleme in der belieferung sketche
geschrieben hat insbesondere bei fast
fashion versuchte vor allem klar zu
machen
von wem das höchste risiko tatsächlich
getragen wird wie mich von denen die am
stärksten gefährdet sind und am
schlechtesten bezahlt werden angst du
hast
man hat immer wieder versucht es zu
verdeutlichen
aber ich hätte nie gedacht dass die
darstellung von dem was man zu
vermitteln versucht so katastrophal ist
und seine plaza war für mich wie eine
regelrechte horrorgeschichte
zwei wochen nach der katastrophe und
einer niederschmetternden opferzahl von
derzeit 9 131 kann man vom schwersten
unglück in der modeindustrie aller
zeiten sprechen
ich glaube dass eines der zutiefst
beeindruckenden dinge des run up laaser
unglücks die nachricht darüber war dass
die arbeiter die missstände des gebäudes
dem management bereits gemeldet haben
sie hatten längst darauf hingewiesen
dass das fundament des mauerwerks
unsicher war und dennoch wurden sie
gezwungen wieder rein zu gehen dann die
reben fußball gehen viele der
überlebenden fragen wieso sie zur arbeit
gezwungen wurden obwohl das management
bereits sowohl über den maroden zustand
des gebäudes bescheid wusste als auch
über die bedenken der arbeiter am tag
des einsturzes sehr viel kleidung in
amerikanischen geschäften wird in
bangladesch von arbeitern hergestellt
die im schnitt zwei dollar am tag
verdienen
letzten monat stürzte eine textilfabrik
ein und riss mehr als 1000 menschen in
den tod
einige monate zuvor tötete ein fabrik
brand mehr als 100 menschen
und während die
und körper aus den trümmern geborgen
wurden fing heute früh eine weitere
fabrik in bangladesch feuer und forderte
acht todesopfer als sich die unglücks
berichte häuften wurde es zu einer
unumstößlichen tatsache dass sich drei
der vier schlimmsten tragödien der
modegeschichte alle in einem jahr
ereignet hatten
so wie die zahl der todesopfer weiter
anstieg so stehen auch die profite
weiter an
das jahr nachdem reiner plasa unglück
war für die bekleidungsindustrie das
profitabelste aller zeiten
die globale modeindustrie erwirtschaftet
nun fast drei billionen dollar im jahr
bangladesch ist jetzt der zweitgrößte
textil exporteur nach china
wie das im gegensatz zu einigen seiner
konkurrenten bleibt die produktion in
bangladesch spottbillig und
gewerkschaften haben nur begrenzten
einfluss
das land ist am absoluten ende der
wertschöpfungskette angelangt 1000 armen
menschen verloren ihr leben weil niemand
sich um sie kümmerte oder einen feuchten
dreck schert sie wollen nur den
billigsten preis und den besten gewinnen
so sollte es nicht sein jeder sollte die
verantwortung für diese kinder tragen
doch es ist wie es ist
es tut mir leid aber es ist nicht nur
der preisdruck
es hat vier meter missachtung des lebens
anderer zu tun
das ist einfach nicht richtig wir sind
doch schließlich im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert in einer globalisierten welt
und wir lassen das leben anderer einfach
so links liegen
wie kann das sein wieso ist diese
gigantische und raffgierige industrie
die so viele gewinne für so wenige
menschen generiert und fähig millionen
ihre arbeit ordnungsgemäß und angemessen
zu entlohnen
warum ist sie nicht imstande deren
sicherheit zu gewährleisten
wir sprechen hier von grundlegenden
menschenrechten wieso ist sie nicht in
der lage diese dinge zu leisten während
sie solche schwindelerregenden profite
erwirtschaftet
liegt es daran dass sie nicht richtig
funktioniert das ist meine frage alles
mag
lucies frage klingt offensichtlich doch
anstatt dass sie beantwortet wurde traf
ich überall auf menschen die immer zu
versuchten die preise zu rechtfertigen
und die wirtschaftlichen vorteile zu
verteidigen
diese niedriglohn ausbeuter betriebe
sogenannte sweatshops sind nicht die
schlechteste option die die arbeiter zu
tage haben sie sind teil eines prozesses
der die lebensstandards und löhne
steigert und im laufe der zeit auch zu
besseren arbeitskonditionen führt
unmittelbare entwicklungs faktoren sind
physisches kapital technologie und
humankapital also die fertigkeiten der
arbeiter
dieses web shops bringen den arbeitern
diese drei faktoren und setzten diesen
prozessen könnte es sein dass diese
sweatshops eigentlich kurz sind
wer genau schreckliche ausbeuter
betriebe allein dieser begriff ruft
furchtbare bilder von armen menschen
online kindern hervor die unter
widrigsten bedingungen die klar dass wir
uns selbst flüchtigen amerikaner
herstellen und vielen dank auch hierfür
beunruhigt es nicht dass menschen in
fabriken arbeiten und kleidung für
amerikaner oder europäer herstellen oder
dass sie auf diese weise ihre leben
verbringen ist es das wonach sie mich
fragen
ja genau
nein sie verrichten einfach nur eine
arbeit es gibt weitaus schlimmere dinge
die sie tun könnten
wir sind live und ich würde sie bitten
ausbeuter betriebe zu definieren wir
reden hier von stücken mit sehr
schlechten arbeitsbedingungen die der
durchschnittsamerikaner folgendermaßen
sind niedrige löhne gemäß unserem
standard vielleicht auch kinder
arbeitsplätze die mit dem lokalen
arbeitsrecht nicht konform sind aber es
gibt andere kernelemente dieser modelle
die ich gerne ansprechen möchte nicht
dass es auch orte gibt an denen menschen
sich ausnutzen können zu arbeiten
zugegeben die auswahl andere
ist nicht gerade toll es gibt ja
eigentlich nichts wirklich gefährliches
an der nähe arbeit an sich wir befinden
uns also in einer relativ ungefährlichen
industrie nicht wie beim bergbau oder in
der erdgasförderung oder in vielen
anderen bereichen die wesentlich
gefährlicher sind natürlich sehen jobs
in den zwei jobs für jeden westler der
wohlhabend genug ist ihr video
anzugucken erstmal nach furchtbaren
arbeitsbedingungen und dumpinglöhnen aus
aber wir müssen dabei auch bedenken dass
die vorhandenen alternativen dieser
arbeiter nicht unsere alternativen sind
sie sind weitaus schlechter hat unsere
und meistens sogar noch viel schlechter
als der fabrik job den der arbeitstags
niedrige löhne und sichere
arbeitsbedingungen und fabrik unglücke
werden alle mit dem argument
entschuldigt dass diese jobs für
menschen ohne alternativen dringend
benötigt werden diese geschichte wird
immer wieder aufgetischt sobald es darum
geht das globale vorgehen der
modeindustrie zu rechtfertigen
aber es gibt auch diejenigen die glauben
dass es einen besseren weg geben muss
mit kleidung zu handeln sie zu
produzieren und mit ihr
wirtschaftswachstum zu erzielen
wir wissen also noch nicht wie lange
dieses stück arbeit dauern wird
könntest du nicht santo fragen wie lange
die ganze stoffbahn group brauchen
könnte wir wollen es ja später in der
ausstellung sehen und da wäre es toll
dass zu wissen ich bin ja vier mini
gründerin und ceo von people to people
tree ist eine fairtrade modemarke die
vor über 20 jahren in japan ins leben
gerufen wurde
du hast dir sorgen gemacht dass wir
vielleicht soviel marineblaue haben
was denkst du jetzt wir haben in der
sommersaison 14 viel spaß verwendet was
mit orders kooperation sehr gut
funktioniert haben wir genug schwarz
drucke in der kollektion mädchen
wir haben den vorlagen abdruck in
schwarz verloren aber ich glaube dieser
rosafarbene abdruck mit dem sich jeder
so schwer tut wird sich gut verkaufen
ich glaube dass die meisten modemarken
mit einem kollektions oder look konzept
anfangen sie denkt er nicht daran wer es
am ende herstellen wird oder wie man
sicherstellen können dass die hersteller
auch etwas zu essen haben was wir bei
people tree versuchen ist zuerst die
fertigkeiten jeder einzelnen produktions
gruppe zu bündeln und dann die
kollektion zu entwerfen ohne dabei die
ganzheitlichkeit und ästhetik der
kollektion aus dem auge zu verlieren
ich habe ursprünglich mit
freiberuflichen designern gearbeitet und
ich bin oft nach bangladesch sind apfel
indien nepal und zu den philippinen
geleistet stück für stück haben wir uns
ein großartiges netzwerk mit
gleichgesinnten fairtrade organisation
aufgebaut die die entwicklung der frauen
als auch der sozialen umgebung der
arbeiter als absolut notwendig ansehen
konzentriert auf die markt
heute ist der 15 jahrestag dieser world
fair trade veranstaltung wir
organisieren diese art von
veranstaltungen in über 60 ländern und
je nach land sind zwischen zehn und 60
verschiedene organisationen mit an bord
heute finden parallel wie wir es auch
hier machen nur das schauen und seminare
in über 3.000 orten auf der ganzen welt
statt
der erste event ihre nationalverbände
[Musik]
könntest du dich etwas mehr zu mir drin
das ist wunderschön fairtrade ist die
bürgerliche antwort auf soziale
ungerechtigkeit in einem internationalen
handelssystem das mehrheitlich völlig
gestört ist bei den arbeitern und bauern
kein existenzminimum gezahlt wird und
die produktionsbedingungen der güter die
wir täglich kaufen überhaupt nicht
beachtet werden
bei wie day
[Musik]
ich heiße china und ich bin 23 jahre alt
ich war zwölf als ich nach dakar casino
branche
[Musik]
nie
china ist eine von 40 millionen
textilarbeitern auf der ganzen welt fast
vier millionen dieser arbeiter leben
hier in bangladesch und arbeiten in fast
5000 fabriken in denen sie die kleidung
für marktführende westliche modell
bisher stellen über 85 prozent dieser
arbeiter sind frauen und der mindestlohn
beträgt weniger als drei dollar am tag
sie gehören zu den am niedrigsten
bezahlten textilarbeitern der welt ich
wohnte zu erstmals an einer tante als
ich zum ersten mal in einer textilfabrik
zu arbeiten begann lag mein lohn sei
streng dollar im monat
[Musik]
meine tochter die hhla die akte
an manchen tagen dem ich sie mit in die
fabrik aber es ist furchtbar heißt dort
und überall gibt es chemikalien die für
kinder sehr schädlich sind wie lange
langfristig kann sie nicht bei mir je in
dakar bleiben weil es in den akten gibt
der sich um sie kümmert range schnell
[Musik]
die arbeiter dürfen keinerlei misstrauen
in den fabrikbesitzer haben wenn sie
dennoch misstrauisch sind kann keine
gute arbeitsatmosphäre in der fabrik
entstehen
sie müssen also respekt haben bei der
besitzer sie gemäß der vereinbarung
bezahlt wenn sie diese art von vertrauen
nicht aufbringen erhält man nicht das
gewünschte resultat
ich habe eine gewerkschaft gegründet in
der ich seit anregungen die präsidentin
denn wir haben hat eine liste mit
ansprüchen eingereicht und die manager
haben sie auch gelesen
darauf folgend gab es heftige
auseinandersetzungen mit den manager im
anschluss schlossen sie die türen und
zusammen mit 30 oder 60 angestellten
griffen uns die manager an und schlugen
auf uns ein
sie nahmen alles stühle stück stoff
wagen aber auch scheren um auf uns
einzuprügeln sie schleuderten sogar
unsere köpfe gegen die wände und
schlugen und traten uns in brust und
unterleib
es wird angenommen dass jeder sechste
auf der welt in irgendeinem teil der
global mode industrie tätig ist was sie
zur größten arbeits abhängigen industrie
der welt macht die meiste arbeit wird
von menschen wie china gemacht menschen
ohne stimme der größten
wertschöpfungskette der geschichte aber
um die auswirkungen zu verstehen die die
modeindustrie auf uns hat müssen wir
dahin zurückkehren wo alles seinen
anfang nahm
meine großeltern siedelten sich in den
20er jahren hier an
das ist also ein teil meiner herkunft
und die leute werden nicht müde zu
fragen wieso ich bio baumwoll farmerin
bin mein opa war in deutschland wird der
festen ansicht war dass man das land und
das leben darauf respektieren muss
wir befinden uns hier in der hochebene
von texas und in dieser region wächst
baumwolle auf einer fläche von etwa
12.000 quadratkilometer
wir sind praktisch das größte baumwoll
gebiet gewählt in nur zehn jahren wurden
80 prozent davon zu genetisch veränderte
baumwolle
das meiste davon ist roundup ready das
heißt anstatt dass die landwirte oder
saisonaler arbeiter hier und da das
unkraut entfernen werden die felder nun
vollständig gespritzt baumwolle
produziert die faser die heutzutage in
der meisten kleidung verwendung findet
und weil unser appetit auf mode immer
weiter anwächst wird die baumwoll
pflanze weiterentwickelt um mithalten zu
können es ist es gab eine enorme
kampagne für die industrialisierung der
landwirtschaft also zur intensivierung
der landwirtschaft und diese trat an die
stelle der alten anbaumethoden die sehr
stark auf die natur und die
jahreszeitlichen zyklen abgestimmt waren
heute sehen wir eine intensivierung bei
der das land fast gleichwertig wie eine
fabrik behandelt es wurde eine
vorgehensweise geschaffen die millionen
von landflächen einfach gleich behandelt
wir kippen einfach eine ladung
chemikalien darüber am ende kriegen wir
massive ökologische nebenwirkungen von
denen keine ahnung hat was da wirklich
passiert
die natur heilt sich bekanntlich selbst
aber nur in kleinen einheiten
doch wenn wir mit dieser riesengroßen
methode dar
dann können wir doch nicht wirklich
wissen was tatsächlich passieren wir
sehen keine wirkliche reduzierung der
pestizide davon ist zwar auf die rede
aber doch nicht in unserer gegend in der
awa million quadratmeter deshalb planes
mit äußerst teurem raunte voll besprüht
werden
welchen einfluss hat das auf unserem
boden der durch die rückstände in einem
mikro bio tisch desaströsen zustand
hinterlassen wird welche auswirkungen
hat das auf die menschen in unseren
gemeinden wo werden die kosten dafür
abgebildet hornberg
monsanto ist stolz darauf industrie
führend in landwirtschaftlichen
innovationen zu sein und in dieser
fortschritte können ihnen dabei helfen
die erträge für die zukünftigen
bedürfnisse der welt wir geben uns der
zukunft der landwirtschaft hin und
versorgen landwirte mit innovationen die
ihnen helfen mehr zu produzieren und
mehr zu erhalten und während das leben
der menschen auf der ganzen welt
verbessert wird zusammen packen wir die
herausforderungen der nächsten
generation an und darüber hinaus
[Musik]
nach den kriegen standen überall diese
lehre fabriken in denen die kriegs
klinika liehen und sprengstoffe
produziert worden waren
die westlichen länder meinten dass es
eine gute idee sei sie an die dritte
welt zu vermarkten
schließlich produziert dieselbe
industrie die sprengstoffe herstellt
auch stickstoffdüngemitteln also fielen
sie in den 1950 er jahren an
nachdem wir unabhängig geworden waren
auf den markt zu drängen
doch die stickstoffdüngemittel vertragen
sich nicht gut mit den heimischen
nutzpflanzen was an lagerungs problemen
liegt daraufhin reorganisierte sich das
ganze system um die pflanze zu
modifizieren damit sie mehr pestizide
vertragen konnte
bt baumwolle ist eine baumwolle bei der
eingehen einer bakterie hinzugefügt
worden ist um ein gift zu produzieren
aber die bt baumwolle die offenbar
schädlinge abwehren kann wurde
eigentlich nur deswegen angeboten weil
es ein ungeheuer einfacher weg für die
konzerne ist das saatgut zu besitzen
durch die patentierung dieser genetisch
modifizierten pflanzen konnte monsanto
zu einem der größten saatgut und
chemiekonzern der geschichte werden
ich wollte unbedingt mit jemandem
sprechen der bereits dort gearbeitet
hatte und ich erfuhr dass ein ehemaliger
geschäftsführer für indien dafür bereit
war ein guter freund von mir der in der
forschung war arbeitete an diesem
modifizierten nutzpflanzen
er kam zu mir ins hotel auf einen drink
und nach ein paar gläsern erzählte er
mir dann hijack die art und weise wie
die geschäfte in indien macht gesetzlich
komplett verändern
ich fragte ihn was das bedeutet er sagte
wir steigen in das saatgutgeschäft ein
und es heißt es soll für alle nutzen
pflanzen gelten so dass wir ein monopol
auf saatgut haben
jeder bauer muss dann zu uns kommen und
jedes mal neues saatgut kaufen sofort
schrillten die alarmglocken in mir auf
wenn ein armer landwirt zu monsanto
gehen muss um jedes mal sein saatgut zu
kaufen und zwar sehr teures saatgut
wie wird es dann mit der bt baumwolle
damals wussten wir noch gar nichts von
genetisch modifizierten saatgut ein
monopol auf saatgut ist etwas sehr
schlechtes bauern müssen sich wegen der
enormen kosten von über 17.000 prozent
über ihrem einkommen extrem hoch
verschulden um das dagegen zu beschaffen
doch die angebliche sichere pflanzen es
ist der bus hält nicht was sie
verspricht so dass sie mehr pestizide
kaufen müssen die tragödie mit
chemikalien ist das ganz gleich ob
jünger oder pestizid alle eine art
ökologisches rauschgift sind je mehr man
sie einsetzt desto mehr braucht man sie
für eine gewisse sicherheit steigt der
gewinn des einzelnen erzeugnisses land
doch dann sagt er wieder ab weil der
boden verseucht worden ist
bringen
der großteil von indiens baumwolle
wächst in der punjab region die sehr
schnell zum größten benutzer von
pestiziden wurde dr pricing hat die
auswirkungen dieser chemikalien auf die
menschliche gesundheit untersucht und
seine berichte weisen auf eine
dramatische zahl an geburtsfehlern krebs
und geisteskrankheiten in dieser region
hin
man kann in jedem dorf hunderte
krebskranker menschen sehen 70 bis 80
kinder in jedem dorf kämpfen mit
geistigen oder körperlichen
behinderungen wegen der sieben menschen
[Musik]
alle unternehmen die düngemittel und
pestizide herstellen streiten diese
nachwirkungen wie himmel ab und hier
sehen sie an typische symptome ihrer
toxizität ein dort hat im schnitt 60
geistig behinderte kinder wie diesen
jungen hier
es ist ein wirklich gefährliches
phänomen in punjab gebiet all die armen
menschen arbeiter landwirte und
kleinbauern sind hier schon längst am
limit angekommen so dass sie sich keine
behandlung mehr leisten können
der level mails so dick im grunde haben
sie sich schon längst mit dem tod ihrer
kinder abgefunden und warten nur noch
darauf dass er kommt diese mutter die
unternehmen die das genmanipuliertes
saatgut herstellen sind dieselben wie
die die chemikalien herstellen aber auch
die medikamente die sie jetzt
patentieren lassen
wenn man also krebs bekommt werden noch
mehr gewinne generiert die cd ist es
eine aufwärts drehende gewünscht gerade
für die menschen und die natur eine
abwärts drehende verluste gerade eine
tages kommen dann die vertreter dieser
unternehmen und sagen zu den bauern das
schuldet mir betrags doch du hast nicht
gezahlt also gehört ein land jetzt mir
an diesem tag geht der bau raus aufs
feld und trinkt eine dieser flaschen mit
dem pestiziden jede witwe mittag sprach
sagte mir dann kamen die nachbarn und
sagten dass sie meinem mann im feld
liegen sagen
in den letzten 16 jahren gab es über
250.000 erfasste selbstmord fälle von
landwirten in indien
das entspricht etwa einem farmer alle 30
minuten und es ist die größte erfasste
selbstmordrate in der geschichte
[Musik]
je klarer die auswirkungen der
modeindustrie für unsere welt werden
desto stärker steigt die zahl an
forschungsbeiträgen die aufzeigen dass
sie genauso auswirkungen auf uns hat den
konsumenten dieser kleidung also 20
jahre und 100 studien später wissen wir
dass je mehr menschen ihren schwerpunkt
auf materialistische werte lägen desto
wichtiger erscheinen für sie geld image
status und besitz zu sein und desto
unglücklicher deprimierter und
verängstigter werden wir wissen dass all
diese psychologischen probleme mit dem
anstieg materieller werte ebenfalls mit
ansteigen
allerdings steht das sind total im
widerspruch mit den abertausenden
werbebotschaften die jeden tag auf uns
einwirken und um suggerieren wollen dass
materialismus unter streben nach besitz
uns glücklicher macht es ist wichtig zu
verstehen dass werbung eine form
beziehungsweise strategie der propaganda
ist wir sehen propaganda als etwas
düsteres und totalitäres lautsprecher
singen der menschenmassen und so weiter
wir denken sofort an hitler und stellen
es uns als etwas ausländisches vor doch
in wirklichkeit ist es so typisch
amerikanisch wie ein hamburger oper
[Musik]
der grund wieso werbung funktioniert ist
dass die schlauen werbefachleute
zumindest versuchen eine botschaft
anzuhängen
die uns operiert dass unsere bedürfnisse
nur durch den kauf dieses produktes es
will dir glauben machen dass sie
wunderschön in diesem teil auf ist doch
wenn du es anziehst siehst du auch zu
dick oder nicht ganz so gut darin aus
und dann tut es mir leid ist gekauft
haben und dann kaufst du eben ein
anderes
[Musik]
doch
mehr
[Musik]
mal nur an die auto reklame denken die
einen vermittelt dass man erst mit
diesem auto zu was gebracht hat oder
sogar zu einer einzelperson wird weil
man jetzt diesen bmw oder audi wurde
china oder die ganzen shampoo werbungen
in denen die person am ende schönes
glänzendes haar hat beliebt ist und von
ihrem umfeld geschätzt die fundamentale
botschaft ist immer dieselbe seine
probleme im leben werden nur durch
konsum gelöst
[Musik]
ich versuche zu verstehen warum menschen
nicht realisieren dass sie eigentlich
immer ärmer werden
und ich frage mich was sich verändert
haben könnte im vergleich zu meiner
jugend die mode ist etwas das sich
drastisch verändert hat ich konnte mir
ein ich zwei oder auch mal 4 t shirts im
jahr leisten
doch jetzt kaufen meine kinder für jede
party ein neues t-shirt
so verstand ich dass fast fashion etwas
völlig neues ist falls es ihm nicht
aufgefallen ist der preis ist in den
letzten jahren gesunken was vom
zunehmenden verschwinden der
mittelklasse kommt doch die dinge die
menschen wirklich brauchen sind sehr
kostenintensiv sowie ein haus ein
studium oder eine lebensversicherung
andererseits ist eine art quelle des
trostes ein fester bestandteil unseres
lebens geworden
ich kann mir ein oder zwei t shirts pro
partie kaufen sogar pro tag und das
obwohl ich sehr arm bw und die dinge
verloren habe die ich wirklich brauchen
heutzutage kaufen wir über 80 milliarden
neuer kleidungsstücke pro jahr das sind
400 mehr als wir uns noch vor zwei
jahrzehnten kauften die art und weise
wie wir kleidung konsumieren hat sich so
stark und so schnell verändert dass
einige menschen einen schritt
zurücktreten um zu versuchen den
ursprung dieses neuen modells und die
konsequenzen einer solchen noch nie
dagewesenen konsum steigerung zu
verstehen es gab mal einen artikel im
seinerzeit führenden werbe magazin
printers inc von einem renommierten
werbetexter namens boernes thermo king
einem sehr bedeutenden man in der kunst
des werbetexten zeigen er begeistert
habe dieser beitrag trug den titel
konsumismus und besagte dass es zwei
verschiedene arten von produkten gibt
die einen die man gebraucht so wie
waschmaschinen autos und so weiter dinge
die man sich langfristig an schafft und
die anderen die man verbraucht
kaugummis zigaretten und andere
kurzlebige konsumgüter
er schrieb dass es beim konsumismus
einzig darum gehe die menschen dazu zu
bringen
gebrauchsgüter wie verbrauchsgüter zu
behandeln er ist das denken der user mit
der innovativen verkaufspolitik 13 preis
von einem
ist ein anzug von joseph banks sogar
billiger als eine küchenrolle und jetzt
gibt es sie sogar in diesem praktischen
spenden an mit vier anzügen zum preis
eines einfachen abendessens habe ich
kein schlechtes gewissen mehr sie
wegzuwerfen wenn ich fertig bin
[Musik]
man muss sich nur mal die mülldeponien
ansehen die menge an textilien die
weggeworfen werden ist in den letzten
zehn jahren stetig angestiegen und das
wird natürlich ein schlechtes licht auf
die fast fashion industrie zwischen
industrie weiter wie unsere spezies
deklarieren und unsere letzten
übriggebliebenen ursprünglichen
instinkte praktisch wegwerfen desto
entschlossener sind wir immer mehr
wegwerfartikel zu produzieren
das macht einfach keinen sinn kleidung
sollte nicht und kann nicht einfach als
wegwerfprodukte gesehen werden also des
motorrad
ich glaube dass es nach jedem großen
industriellen wandel ist man sehr lange
dauert bis man den track einer
verschmutzten sache riechen und sehen
kann und ich denke dass jetzt wieder
eine wende statt findet man einfach
nicht mehr verleugnen kann dass die fast
fashion industrie massive negative
auswirkungen auf die entwicklungsländer
hat der durchschnittsamerikaner wirft
etwa 37 kilo an textil abfällen weg pro
jahr
das bedeutet mehr als elf millionen
tonnen an textil abfällen allein in den
usa
das meiste davon ist nicht biologisch
abbaubar was bedeutet dass sie für die
nächsten 200 jahre oder länger auf den
deponien bleiben werden während sie
schadstoffe ausstoßen
ein riesiger teil davon ist schillig
kleidung und viele menschen glauben dass
sie etwas gutes damit tun kleidung zu
spenden
die reise allein eines t shirts das an
eine hilfsorganisation gespendet wird
ist absurd und wieder wersen an karate
wallén 12
er ist eine wahre krankheit in haiti und
nicht nur in haiti sondern in praktisch
jedem entwicklungsland kann man sagen es
ist ein gewaltiges problem pp heißt ein
haupt kleidung das meist aus den staaten
die menschen kommen und kaufen
kistenweise die kleidung und wissen
nicht mal was sie kaufen
das ist kleidung die an
hilfsorganisationen gespendet worden ist
und in den sec and leben der
organisation nicht verkauft wird
sie wird verpackt und in die dritte welt
länder verschickt und das meist nur zehn
prozent der kleidung die wir spenden
wird in secondhandläden bei uns verkauft
und je schneller wir uns umziehen desto
mehr wird in entwicklungsländer wie
haiti ausrangiert durch die steigende
menge der secondhand kleidung in haiti
ist die lokale textilindustrie praktisch
verschwunden
einstmals gab es hier einen stolzen
schneiderei zweig heute produziert er
überwiegend billig t shirts für den
export nach amerika früher als man dort
noch gearbeitet hat hat man ständig neue
leute gesehen
sie hatten den wunsch und die hoffnung
dass näherei handwerk zu lernen
vielen wurde es bei gebracht und dadurch
gewannen sie die zuversicht mit diesen
fähigkeiten einen guten job zu finden
heutzutage wird einem zwar noch gezeigt
immer nett aber die chancen davon leben
zu können sind praktisch hoffnungslos
ich sage den leuten ständig dass es
nicht gut dass dinge zu kaufen weil sie
nutzen den dollar kosten
heute wenn man in einem baguette oder so
kommt man sich vorher ein kleid 14
dollar weil es so billig ist denkt man
schon gar nicht mehr darüber nach ist
und wenn es nicht mehr gefällt wirft man
es weg und man macht dasselbe immer und
immer wieder
während das bewusstsein über den
einfluss der mode auf unsere welt wächst
fangen industrie fachleute an die
auswirkungen eines auf fahrlässiger
produktion und auf endlosen konsum
basierenden konzeptes zu hinterfragen
wir bei patagonia hassen den begriff
verbraucher es muss ein besseres wort
geben wir bevorzugen eher kunden und
zwar solche kunden die den einfluss
ihres konsums erkannt haben nämlich dass
sie als konsumenten auch teil des
problems sind wir sind sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir unsere kunden
dazu ermutigen sich uns beim
hinterfragen des konsums anzuschließen
testen denn ohne reale reduzierung des
konsums haben wir nicht das gefühl eine
kollektive lösung für die anstehenden
probleme zu finden nämlich dem
fortschreitenden rückgang der gesundheit
unseres planeten
die modeindustrie muss hier eigentlich
nur anfang ihrer arbeitsweise zu
überdenken und die konventionellen
formen in frage stellt für mich als
modedesignerin ist dies das aufregendste
im moment viel aufregender als die
farben der saison auszusuchen oder
schnitte und rocking festzulegen ich
finde es in meiner branche viel
herausfordernder zu sagen ich werde es
diesmal auf eine umweltschonende rat
versuchen
der handel hat durch die werbungen der
gesellschaft eingeredet dass
glückseligkeit in dingen liegt und das
wahre glückseligkeit nur durch den
jährlichen saisonalen wöchentlichen
täglichen arbeit von immer mehr singen
erreicht werden kann
wir wollen unsere kunden dazu anregen
genau über diese suggestionen
nachzudenken um zu verstehen woher sie
kommen und durch dieses verständnis
können wir alle zusammen diesen
vermittelt haben es da die kunden müssen
lernen dass sie diejenigen sind die die
verantwortung tragen und sie sind wir
arbeitslos und das ist äußerst mich
nicht man ist überhaupt nicht
verpflichtet daran zu glauben wenn es
einem nicht gefällt
ich liebe diese stück arbeit antun
ja sie ist wirklich sehr schön findest
du nicht dass wir die stickerei auf
beiden seiten machen sollten
ich finde wir müssen sie auch hier
anbringen es sieht irgendwie geil sich
aus wenn sie nur vorn ist werden wir es
doch auf beide seiten das wird nicht
viel mehr kosten oder
ist ein fairtrade modeunternehmen aber
auch eine art entwicklungsgesellschaft
sie hilft über 3000 menschen in diesem
dorf snow village
ich komme etwa alle vier monate her
wir nennen das produktions trips und wir
arbeiten mit den erzeugern zusammen um
herauszufinden was die hindernisse sind
um ein großartiges produkt herzustellen
und um es richtig zu vermarkten
wir betreiben zudem auch hilfe zur
selbsthilfe und schauen uns auch hier
die hindernisse an um mehr
sozialleistungen zu fördern und um den
umweltschutz in diesem gebiet zu
verbessern
für mich geht es hier um partnerschaft
und um eine gemeinsame erarbeitung von
kreativen lösungen mit dem ganzen team
probleme zu erkennen und einen weg zu
finden der für alle funktioniert
ich möchte den besten mitarbeiter und
eine weibliche repräsentantin von salons
im august oder im nächsten frühling zu
mir nach london einladen
ich werde sie darüber nachdenkt wer
dafür am besten wäre denn ihr sollt
wissen wer ihre kunden sind verstehen
wie der markt richtig funktioniert und
ein jeder von berichten wenn ihr wieder
zurück
[Musik]
ich habe schon das möglich jeder fahrer
wenn sie es erst krank ich macht sollte
sich vielleicht dichter ansetzen muss
darum für ss 15
das kann sie mit uns kommen und uns das
nächste zeigen was sie macht
ich hoffte insgeheim das porträt nicht
notwendig wäre und dass wir ein anderes
handelssystem hätte dass die
menschenrechte achtet und die umwelt
respektiert aber je länger ich in der
entwicklung involviert war und enger mit
gewissen partnern zusammen arbeitete
desto mehr schreckliche handelspraktiken
entdeckte ich die alles unterminieren
woran wir und die meisten menschen
glauben und was wir wertschätzen people
tree entwickelte sich organisch aus
einer großartigen gruppe heraus die fest
daran glaubt dass es einen anderen weg
gehen muss wie man arbeitet lebt
konsumiert und mit anderen menschen auf
humane weise interagiert ich hätte nie
gedacht dass people tree einmal in
tausenden läden verkauft wird
ich sehe noch so viele stellen die wir
anpacken müssen und ich denke dass es
nicht nur um das schaffen von 7000
arbeitsplätzen bei people tree geht
sondern auch darum dass man zu einer
veränderung der industrie beiträgt und
zeigt dass unser geschäftsmodell
funktioniert
[Musik]
als wir mit dem biologischen anbau
begannen gab es damals nur zwei oder
drei biopharma und wir gründeten die
texas organic cotton marketing
kooperative die vereinbarung war dass
sie anbauen und ich verkaufe ich fing an
mit senatorin wie jacob javits über die
baumwolle pflanzen zu sprechen und alle
sahen uns nur noch an als wären wir
völlig verrückt geworden
oft werden konsumenten auf bio milch
aufmerksam durch eine ausgebrochene
allergie zum beispiel aber baumwolle und
andere stoffe die man an die haut lässt
alarmiert sie interessanterweise nicht
und das obwohl die haut das größte organ
ist dass wir haben bei lebensmitteln ist
ist einfacher beim bio apfel nämlich
keine chemikalien und pestizide auf doch
bei kleidung wird diese verbindung nicht
hergestellt darum muss man die dinge aus
einer entfernteren perspektive
betrachten
es betrifft auch unsere luft unseren
ganzen planeten und uns menschen erst
dann bekommt man das richtige
bewusstsein auch wenn man erst mal denkt
dass man selbst nicht unmittelbar
eingreift durch den kauf eines bio endes
doch da einfluss zeigt sich im großen
gesamtbild und ganz besonders an den
orten wo die baumwolle angebaut wird
wir als biopharma warten auf den eisigen
frust denn er entblättert die pflanzen
und wenn wir dann ernten öffnen sich die
reifen kapseln die die baumwolle
beinhalten
der sogenannte baumwollpflücker der hier
dann drüber fährt heißt so weil er mit
einer art finger gabel die baumwolle
tatsächlich glück da hinten kann man
diese maschine sehen wie sie schon das
halbe feld eingesammelt hat
[Musik]
ich glaube eines der größten probleme
des derzeitigen modells ist dass der
profit im mittelpunkt steht und es
berücksichtigt einfach nicht alle kosten
wie zb die kosten von
wasserverschmutzung die kosten von
arbeitskraft die kosten für die gitter
an den fenstern wenn menschen in einer
fabrik sterben wenn ein feuer ausbricht
die kosten für landwirte die keinen
zugang zur bildung von krankenkassen
haben ohne das wissen wir nicht was der
wahre preis eigentlich ist
krank uhr liegt am großen ganges dem
heiligsten aller flüsse ist äußerst
wichtig für 800 millionen hindus und
dient als lebensader für nordindien
doch dieser fluss wird immer stärker
verschmutzt und von den leder fabriken
in campo völlig zerstörten beliebte
event geld bei der durch die stark
wachsende nachfrage nach billigem leder
wurde kann kur zur hauptstadt des
indischen leder exporten
[Musik]
jeden tag werden hier über 50 millionen
liter giftiges abwasser aus lokalen
gerbereien ausgeschieden schwere
chemikalien die zur lederverarbeitung
eingesetzt werden wie das kronos sieht
gelangen den die lokale landwirtschaft
und sogar ins trinkwasser an orten wie
kantor fernab der sichtweite der welt
können führende westliche marken billige
materialien beschaffen und sich aus
ihrer verantwortung gegenüber der
ansteigenden kosten für gesundheit und
umwelt entziehen
[Musik]
in der ddr die menschen in dieser gegend
sitzen in der falle wegen der gerberei
verschmutzung die ganze umgebung ist
verschmutzt ebenso grund und boden
die einzige trinkwasserquelle das
grundwasser ist mit chrome kontaminiert
landwirtschaftliche erzeugnisse wie
salat und gemüse werden dort angebaut
die gesundheit der menschen ist sehr
beeinträchtigt und es gibt viele
verschiedene hautprobleme wie ausschläge
geschwüre pusteln sogar taubheitsgefühle
in den gliedmaßen
sie leiden an magenerkrankungen
möglicherweise auch an krebs meine
tochter leidet an gelbsucht fast in
jedem zweiten haus leitet irgendjemand
an irgendetwas und das wird von jahr zu
jahr immer mehr all unsere ersparnisse
fließen in die behandlung dieser
krankheiten weil dieses aggressive
chrome in unserem wasser die leber
direkt angreift es verursacht
verdauungsprobleme und viele kriegen
davon gelbsucht oder sogar leberkrebs
weil sie nicht imstande sind angemessene
vorkehrungen zu treffen
man kann die besten materialien in den
luxusläden in mailand paris oder london
finden aber es steckt soviel unsichtbare
arbeit drin so viele chemikalien wurden
über abwässer in die flüsse abgeleitet
aber wir sehen zu diesem zeitpunkt nur
das fertige produkt ohne looping depp
und auch da im internet findet pro tag
wir müssen einen gang runterschalten und
darüber nachdenken
die modebranche ist heute die am
zweitstärksten verschmutzen industrie
der welt gleich hinter der ölindustrie
das alarmierende ist nicht nur das mode
einen gewaltigen anteil an ressourcen
auf braucht und gigantische auswirkungen
auf die umwelt hervorruft sondern auch
dass diese ressourcen und auswirkungen
meist gar nicht bemessen werden
die kassetten zur bande weil diese
ressourcen so reichlich vorhanden waren
nahmen wir an dass sie auf ewig
ausreichen würden darum hat der handel
sie nie in die gleichung mit einbezogen
wir erleben hier erst seit den 1950 er
jahren diese industrielle ausdehnung in
einem maße in dem wir exponentielles
wachstum und exponentielle verwendung
von ressourcen sehen das erste
wirtschaftssystem auf dem unser leben
basiert ist die natur wirtschaft diese
wirtschaft ist zwar riesig wird aber
nicht gezählt dann haben wir die
wirtschaft der menschen der arbeitenden
männer und frauen der bauern
doch das alles wurde durch dieses
konstrukt unsichtbar gemacht
zuerst in der großen depression und dann
während der kriegsjahre die zahl der iss
bruttoinlandsprodukt verzeichnet wird
misst nur das womit gehandelt wird
und das wurde zum neuen rohstoff
viele ressourcen die wir für unsere
kleidung verwenden werden gar nicht in
die produktionskosten mit einberechnet
also die kosten für das wasser die
landflächen zum anbau der fasern die
chemikalien zum färben
all diese dinge sind eingaben und als
eingaben kosten sie natürlich etwas aber
sie geben auch etwas aus in manchen
fällen haben sie gute ausgaben wie die
kleidung selbst oder arbeitsplätze
doch in anderen fällen geben sie sehr
schlechte dinge aus wie schädliche
chemikalien oder treibhausgase
aber auch diese dinge haben ihre kosten
leg dich auf das kissen wirst du traurig
sein wenn du nadia wieder verlassen muss
natürlich werde ich traurig sein aber
was soll ich denn anderes machen mit
meinem job hier bin ich gezwungen sie im
dorf unterzubringen
sie hat in den letzten zwei monaten fast
nichts für die schule gelernt sie sieht
nur vertritt filme oder musikvideos
aber wenn sie im dorf ist geht das nicht
mehr denn dann geht sie morgens in die
schule und kommt zum mittagessen wieder
heim und um 3 geht sie dann zum
privatunterricht das wäre hier unmöglich
und was machst du jetzt mit na ja
manchmal lasse ich sie bei den nachbarn
manchmal kümmert sich der vater um sie
und manchmal nehme ich sie mit in die
fabrik sowie gestern motto willkommen
hieß
dieselben niedriglöhne die bangladesch
zu einem attraktiven geschäftszentrum
für marken gemacht haben ließen
millionen arbeiter immense überstunden
ableisten so dass es für viele unmöglich
wurde ihre kinder bei sich zu behalten
sogar in den schlimmsten slums um ihren
kindern eine ausbildung und die chance
auf eine bessere zukunft als in den
fabriken zu ermöglichen lassen viele
fabrikarbeiterinnen wie china ihre
kinder bei der familie oder bei freunden
in den dörfern in der hoffnung sie ein
bis zweimal im jahr sehen zu können
das ist mein vater ich habe ihn vor
einem jahr zuletzt gesehen manchmal
telefonieren wir aber gesehen haben wir
uns vor einem jahr
und das ist meine mutter und auch wir
haben uns zuletzt vor einem jahr gesehen
mit telefonieren ab und zu aber sehen
uns nur selten
[Musik]
die mühen der arbeiter in bangladesch
sind grenzenlos jeden tag waren wir früh
morgens auf gehen in die fabrik und
arbeiten den ganzen tag wirklich schwer
und mit all unserer harten arbeit
stellen wir die kleidung her kleidung
die die menschen auf der ganzen welt
tragen
doch diesen menschen wissen oft nicht
wie schwer es für uns ist diese kleidung
herzustellen
sie kaufen und tragen sie nur ich finde
dass diese kleidung auch mit unserem
blut produziert wird denn bereits viele
fabrikarbeiter starben bei schweren
unfällen sowie lässt es ja der fabrik
anschluss von run up lasag mehr gewonnen
viele menschen sind dort ums leben
gekommen
es ist sehr schmerzhaft für uns und ich
will nicht dass jemand etwas trägt das
mit unserem blut hergestellt worden ist
mit einer der piloten bessere
arbeitsbedingungen für uns dass jeder
darauf aufmerksam dass in homberg pokal
müssen ob ich will keine weiteren
inhaber wie den von varna plaza der so
viel riskiert hat und die arbeiter unter
solchen bedingungen zur arbeit gezwungen
hat überlegt wie ich will dass niemand
messen sterben muss dass keine mittel
ihre kinder auf diese weise verlieren
müssen
ich will dass die inhaber mehr
verantwortung übernehmen und mehr auf
uns achten
die profis eigentlich nutzen wie ihr
bedürfnis nach arbeit aus um sie als
sklaven ich sage nicht dass wir das
lassen sollten nein wir müssen ihnen
arbeit geben aber sie müssen mit
demselben respekt behandelt werden mit
dem wir unsere kinder und freunde
behandeln fordert eine drastische
veränderung in der modeindustrie
sie machte schlagzeilen mit der green
carpet challenge in dem sie stars und
top designer dazu aufforderte teil einer
aufmerksamen mode gestaltung zu werden
sie betreibt ein beratungsunternehmen
für nachhaltigkeit namens eco engine
wurde auf einer konferenz geladen um
über die zukunft der mode zu sprechen
es reiche wenn es fast fashion nicht
gäbe bräuchten wir kein treffen in
kopenhagen um zu versuchen die
zerstörung der umwelt und der sozialen
gerechtigkeit die in den letzten 20
jahren verursacht worden ist zu beheben
existenz was fasching fast fashion
möchte schnell produzieren also müssen
die fabrikarbeiter schneller und
billiger produzieren
daher sind die fabrikarbeiter das
einzige glied in der wertschöpfungskette
bei denen die spanne gedrückt wird
wir haben diese riesigen unternehmen die
in den fabriken von bangladesch
auftragsvolumina von 1,5 millionen jeans
erteilen jeweils für 30 cent oder 50
cent
wie kommen so etwas ethisch
rechtfertigen ich weiß es nicht
aber ist es auch aus sicht der
verbraucher wirklich demokratisch ein t
shirt für 5 dollar zu kaufen oder eine
jeans von 20 dollar oder ziehen die uns
über den tisch
sie lassen uns glauben dass wir reich
und wohlhabend sind weil wir uns viel
kaufen können aber in wirklichkeit
machen sie uns nur ärmer und die
einzigen die reicher werden sind die
inhaber dieser fast fashion machen
das macht mich etwas ärgerlich und dann
ist mir lieber
sie haben über die verpflichtung des
versuchs und des versprechens eines
grundeinkommens gesprochen
levin weight was bedeutet das wie
definiert man überhaupt ein faires
existenzminimum in bangladesch
was heißt das genau ein pilotversuch in
drei fabriken zu haben mit dem ergebnis
dass 15 euro fabriken so etwas bis 2018
umsetzen sollen das ist nicht
ausreichend
bei weitem nicht ist unseres erachtens
sollte die definition eines
existenzminimums von den arbeitern
kommen und das sollte in unserer
arbeitsweise integriert werden und wie
hoch sollte sein und steht es nicht zu
einer höhe zu beziffern
aber wir machen regelmäßig fitz noch mal
so hoch ist es ist die grundbedürfnisse
der arbeit
ich kann es dann später gerne zeigen
h&m hat das modell der fast fashion
perfektioniert und ist heute der
zweitgrößte bekleidungskonzern der
geschichte mit einem jährlichen umsatz
von fast 18 milliarden us dollar sie
sind einer der größten
bekleidungshersteller sowohl in
bangladesch als auch in kambodscha
leider haben sie wie auch alle anderen
großen händler die ich gefragt habe alle
interviewfragen für diesen film
abgelehnt
in kambodscha hatten die fabrikarbeiter
irgendwann genug und sind vor kurzem auf
die straße um für eine erhöhung des
mindestlohns zu streiken
doch als die proteste weiter anhielten
wurden die arbeiter und arbeiterinnen
auf brutale weise zurückgedrängt und die
polizei eröffnete sogar das feuer auf
sie mit scharfer munition
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die frau kam bei den zusammenstößen
zwischen textilfabrik arbeitern und der
polizei in kambodscha ums leben viele
wurden verletzt
[Musik]
zwei tage lang war kambodscha ein
einziges schlachtfeld vor allem die
hauptstadt phnom penh polizei und
fallschirmjäger rückten an als ob es
einen bürgerkrieg geben
und warum weil die arbeiter der
textilindustrie auf einen mindestlohn
von 160 dollar warten
[Musik]
die regierung ging mit aller härte gegen
uns vor und dabei wurden fünf arbeiter
getötet 23 verhaftet und über 60
verletzt
dabei verlangen wir doch überhaupt nicht
viel geld wir möchten doch auch noch
einen angemessenen lohn um ein
anständiges und würdevolles leben zu
führen
doch der regierung ist es egal wie arm
sind oder wie sehr wir schon gelitten
haben
die arbeiter sind denen völlig egal und
daher verlangen wir weiterhin einen
mindestlohn von 160 dollar im monat
heute ist das begräbnis eines
fabrikarbeiters der zu tode geprügelt
worden ist er hatte vor seinem tod heute
morgen sehr schwer gelitten
ich freue mich dass die monarchie
dabei hat er nichts falsches getan und
seine arbeitskollegen wollten nur
bessere lebensbedingungen wanted to have
been living conditions
[Musik]
wir werden diesen kampf weiterführen
sodass alle kambodschanischen arbeiter
irgendwann angemessene
arbeitsbedingungen bekommen werden
[Musik]
die
die kambodschanische regierung sowie die
anderen entwicklungsländer trachten
verzweifelt nach den geschäften mit den
multinationalen konzern wegen der
ständigen bedrohung dass diese marken
ihre produktionen in andere länder
verlagern könnten drückt die regierung
einerseits die löhne und übergeht
andererseits regelmäßig das arbeitsrecht
aber weil die groß marken ihre arbeit
nicht offiziell einstellen
beziehungsweise die fabriken nicht deren
eigentum sind sind sie in der lage
gigantische profite einzufahren und
gleichzeitig keinerlei verantwortung für
die armutslöhne fabrik unglücke und
permanente gewaltsame behandlung der
arbeiter zu übernehmen
das ganze system fühlt sich langsam an
wie ein perfekt konstruierte albtraum in
dem die arbeiter gefangen sind
man kann uns nicht täuschen uns unsere
arbeitskraft berauben und auch noch
unsere arbeiter ausbeuten
sie werden ihren kampf weiterführen ich
rufe die internationalen marken dazu auf
unserem täglichen kampf in dollars in
pfund in euros aufzuwiegen
es rechnet sich unmittelbar um in
menschliches kapital und soziale
verantwortung dieser großkonzerne und es
verwandelt sich in wirtschaftlicher
gerechtigkeit wenn es wenn sich alles
nur noch auf die profit generierung für
die konzerne konzentriert sieht man wie
die menschenrechte umwelt und
arbeitsrecht allesamt verloren gehen man
sieht dass die arbeiter immer stärker
ausgebeutet werden weil die preise
ständig runter gedrückt werden und das
alles nur um diesen impuls nach mehr
kapital anhäufen zu befriedigen
das ist zutiefst problematisch weil es
zur massen verelendung von hunderten
millionen menschen auf der ganzen welt
fährt wenn man solche firmen an schreibt
schicken sie die ihren verhaltenskodex
zu und er ist immer wunderschön
formuliert mit dingen wie wir übernehmen
verantwortung für die bedingungen unter
denen unsere produkte hergestellt werden
wir erwarten von allen fabriken die wir
beauftragen dass sie die mindestlohn
gesetze einhalten die landesgesetze
einhalten die frauen respektieren keine
kinder einstellen keine zwangsarbeit
einsätzen keine exzessive überstunden
usw
doch als wir dem kongress vor ein paar
jahren einen gesetzesentwurf vorlegten
den wir gesetz für angemessene
arbeitskonditionen und fairen wettbewerb
nannten antwortet die alle konzerne
einstimmig um gottes willen das wäre ja
ein hemmnis für den freien handel
wir dürfen keine regulierungen haben das
geht doch nicht sie möchten es partout
bei freiwilligen verhaltensnormen
belassen
ich meine sie haben auch darum gekämpft
und rechte gewonnen die ihre dinge und
interessen konkret schützen
aber was ist mit den arbeitern die
bleiben auf freiwilligen
verhaltensgrundsätze sitzen und was wir
in immer mehr fällen beobachten ist dass
diese freiwilligen grundsätze nicht
einmal das papier wert sind auf dem sie
stehen
mini zurück wir müssen besonders in der
modeindustrie anerkennt das humankapital
ein erheblicher teil dieser wundersamen
formel ist ohne das human kraft
teil ohne billige besonders weibliche
arbeitskraft würde solche profite gar
nicht erst geben
das muss endlich anerkannt werden und es
muss eine auseinandersetzung stattfinden
dass dieser menschen entlohnt und nicht
ausgebeutet werden
was ist deren anteil ist das sollte eine
ständige zentrale frage sein
sind diese käufer unmoralisch oder sind
sie einfach nur amoralisch das system
für das sie arbeiten und das system dass
firmen so etwas erlaubt ist amoralisch
die betroffenen individuell sind einfach
nur ein produkt dieses systems was wir
tun müssen ist das verhalten dieser
firmen zu ändern dies operate in einem
system das nur gewinne gemacht haben
firmen wenig anreiz etwas anderes zu tun
als den umsatz im nächsten quartal zu
steigern
ganz gleich welche schäden dabei
verursacht werden sowohl konzerne aus
der textil als auch aus der chemie
industrie und der landwirtschaft wachsen
heutzutage zu noch nie dagewesenen
größen und macht ordnungen heran
diese oberste direktive der
gewinnmaximierung um jeden preis steht
im direkten gegensatz zu unseren werten
richard wolf ein ökonom der seinen
abschluss in harvard stanford und yale
absolviert hat ist davon überzeugt dass
das wahre problem im system selbst liegt
zu einem fremden land geworden
man darf das bildungssystem kritisieren
um die schulen zu verbessern oder das
transportsystem um die infrastrukturen
zu verbessern aber das wirtschaftssystem
darf man nicht kritisieren
es hat quasi ein freischein man darf es
einfach nicht und wenn man etwas seit 50
jahren nicht mehr hinterfragt fängt es
an zu schimmeln eine gesunde
gesellschaft kann nur dann richtig
funktionieren wenn sich alle
systemkomponenten der kritik unterziehen
lassen damit wir sie diskutieren können
um sie wieder zu richten oder zu
verbessern
der kapitalismus aber durfte nicht
hinterfragt werden
realismus ist der grund wieso die
modeindustrie orte so ist darum haben
arbeiter in einer durch einen sehr
niedrigen lohn
denn wenn man in einem kapitalistischen
system arbeitet ist das wichtigste
gewinne zu machen und zwar immer mehr
als die konkurrenz
das spornt die konzerne an die löhne
noch weiter zu drücken und die ganzen
modemarken gehen aus einem einzigen
grund an orten wie bangladesch nämlich
immer nur um die billigste arbeitskraft
zu bekommen dann hat keine festen tarif
keine gewerkschaften einen extrem
niedrigen mindestlohn kein motor schützt
keine rentenkassen
darum setzt die modeindustrie in
bangladesch weil es die größten profite
aus diesen münchen herausholen kann
bevor man ein problem lösen kann muss
man erst eingestehen dass es eines gibt
und bevor wir ein wirtschaftssystem
reparieren können dass auf diese weise
agiert und solche spannungen
ungleichheiten und aufregung in unserer
gesellschaft produziert müssen wir das
wahre ausmaß des problems erst einmal
erkennen und das ist das system als
ganzes
erst dann sollte eine nationale debatte
gestartet werden in der wir lange und
tiefgründig über besser funktionierende
alternative systeme nachdenken die
größte bedrohung für die umwelt ist dass
das kapital unendlich expandieren muss
um zu überleben
es darf keine grenzen in ausbreitung und
wachstum haben die natürliche welt hat
logischerweise grenzen die ganz klar
definieren wie viel der planet ertragen
kann bezüglich produktion handel
transport und distribution
es ist ziemlich offensichtlich dass wir
viele dieser grenzen bereits
überschritten haben weswegen wir im
moment solchen stress in der natürlichen
welt erleben
das system in dem sie leben entspricht
überhaupt nicht den vorstellungen der
meisten menschen
ich denke es macht die meisten menschen
sehr unglücklich und ich denke nicht
dass menschen auf einem langsam dahin
siechenden planeten leben oder von ihrem
nachbarn ausgebeutet werden wollen ich
glaube wir brauchen einen gewaltigen
systemischen wandel
wenn man das system nicht verändert hält
man die entscheidungsgewalt dieser
konzerne intakt das bedeutet dass eine
kleine gruppe von führungskräften und
inszenieren weiterhin im selben system
arbeiten werden dass abhängig ist von
denselben formen von zuckerbrot und
peitsche und sie früher oder später dazu
bringen wird irgendwo dieselben
bedingungen wieder zu schaffen gegen die
wir jetzt anzukämpfen versuche man muss
aufhören zu versuchen die bedingungen zu
verbessern und anfangen etwas am system
zu unternehmen sonst meint man es nicht
ab unser wirtschaftssystem ist der
konsum kapitalismus deswegen braucht die
regierung einen sehr hohen konsumismus
natürlich machen die konzerne damit und
deswegen fangen die menschen irgendwann
auch damit an die meisten mit denen ich
darüber gesprochen habe entgegnet mir
dann aber wenn wir den materialismus
zurückschrauben wird die wirtschaft
zusammenbrechen
das stimmt natürlich bis zu einem
gewissen grad weil unsere wirtschaft auf
materialistischen werten fundiert das
ist teil ihres antriebs um zu überleben
das problem ist nur dass ein wirklich
hoher preis dafür gezahlt wird der white
frei der einkaufs man findet mal wieder
heute abend in den amerikanischen
kaufhäusern statt mancherorts erscheint
es als ob jemand bekannt gegeben hätte
dass die bestände für immer ausgehen
könnten und man besser alles stehen und
liegen lassen sollte machte über 10
millionen transaktionen in den ersten
vier stunden
der schwarze freitag ist der stärkste
tag im ganzen jahr für den einzelhandel
und hier bei macy's machen wir so viel
umsatz an diesem tag wie an keinem
anderen im jahr
diese weihnachtsbummel orgie beweist
dass amerika wieder zurück ist wir sind
wieder vereint
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir geben wieder geld aus das wir nicht
haben für dinge die wir nicht brauchen
um sie menschen zu schenken die wir
nicht mögen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
juli
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe das gemacht haben sind feld
gehen
warum
sie lieben die kleinen leon sie können
besser auf sie aufpassen als ich es kann
aber ein fachlich doch traurig
unabhängig davon wie sehr es geliebt
wird cantona ein kind so sehr lieben wie
die eigenen eltern
ich bin tot unglücklich
[Musik]
ich will nicht dass meine tochter so wie
ich in einer textilfabrik arbeiten muss
ich mache mir sorgen aber eines tages
werde ich wieder glücklicher sein wenn
ich weiß dass sie eine bessere zukunft
sie wird ein guter mensch und die leute
werden sagen dass ihre mutter ihr eine
gute ausbildung und erziehung ermöglicht
hat und das obwohl sie in einer
textilfabrik in dhaka arbeitete seit weg
von ihrer tochter man spürt wo sie
untergebracht wenn sie beamtin wird oder
einen guten mann heiratet werden die
menschen wissen dass ich sehr stolz bin
und dass ich darum gekämpft und mein
bestes versucht habe damit sie nicht
dasselbe durchstehen mussten die ich
dass ich sie gut erzogen habe mit dem
mann spricht
[Musik]
ich wuchs auf einer farm auf was habe
einen mann geheiratet er auch auf einer
farm aufgewachsen war und wir legten auf
einer farm natürlich legten wir viel
wert auf sicherheit
doch diese neuartigen chemikalien und
die intensität in der sie angewendet
wurden stiegen stetig an lassen dann im
jahr 2005 fing terry an einige
feinmotorische fähigkeiten zu verlieren
bis wir herausfanden dass er
glioblastoma multiforme hatte einen
hirntumor vierten grades in der
blütezeit seines lebens mit 47 er starb
schließlich mit 50 obwohl die ärzte ihm
nur noch sechs monate gegeben hat rabat
riesige krebs kliniken und medizinische
zentren
darum mussten wir für die operation zum
glück nicht woanders hin
wir konnten auch deswegen hier bleiben
weil der chirurg so viele dieser tumore
behandelte er sagte uns dass diese art
überwiegend bei männern im alter
zwischen 45 und 65 auftritt sie in der
landwirtschaft oder in der ölindustrie
tätig sind
leider habe ich keinen eindeutigen
beweis oder einen bluttest der aufzeigt
dass die nutzung von baumwolle und
agrarchemikalien unmittelbar zum tod
meines mannes geführt hat obwohl es auch
viele ähnliche verknüpfungen mit dem tod
seines vaters gibt
wir wuchsen auf chemie intensiven farben
auf und legten inmitten von 3,6
millionen quadratmetern ak die viele
pestizide benötigten zu diesem zeitpunkt
wurde bioanbau nicht mehr nur wichtig
für mich sondern zwingend notwendig es
ist auch zwingend notwendig dass wir die
landwirtschaft verändern und dass wir
wenn wir von langfristiger
nachhaltigkeit an dem wohl unseres
lebens und das unserer kinder sprechen
auch uns verändern müssen
[Musik]
das ist der beginn einer kehrtwende und
zwar nicht nur um mode auf
verantwortungsvolle weise zu machen
sondern um die formen des kapitalismus
und die des wirtschaftens zu erneuen ich
bin mir sicher dass wir eine
signifikante veränderungen in den
kommenden zehn jahren erleben werden ob
sie noch rechtzeitig geschieht ist eine
andere frage
martin luther king junior sagte mal bei
einer predigt in brooklyn das was
amerika bräuchte wäre eine revolution
der werte es müsse aufhören menschen wie
gegenstände zu behandeln und damit
aufhören profite über die menschen zu
stellen um stattdessen menschen mit
diesen propheten auf humane weise zu
behandeln jungen bei gott wir könnten es
doch viel besser lösen wenn wir wollen
und zwar wenn wir die industrie wie ich
es immer fördere auf der welt verteilen
würden
anstatt sie an einem zentrum zu
konzentrieren lasst uns doch auch den
nutzen globalisiert teilen und zwar auf
ordnungsgemäß adäquater und sorgfältiger
weise wissen erkennen das kapital nur
geld ist und geld ein snack mittel die
menschen sollten dafür verantwortlich
gemacht werden wie damit umgegangen wird
und wir müssen die schöpfungskraft der
menschenwürdigen und anfangen von
kreativität zu sprechen an stelle von
arbeit wie nie tut mir dürfen land nicht
als eine wahre ansehen
mit der spekuliert oder gehandelt werden
kann
sondern als die lebensgrundlage von uns
also für smart voucher in schortens
wir müssen alle verbraucher in
aktivisten verwandeln die moralische
fragen stellen und zwar ganz einfache
fragen zum beispiel über die herkunft
der kleidung
sie müssen für sich sagen dass es
inakzeptabel ist wenn jemand an seinem
arbeitsplatz sterben muss wir können sie
doch nicht einfach machen lassen was sie
wollte es hat so viele globale negative
auswirkungen auf millionen von menschen
und auf gemeinsame rohstoffe
werden wir weiterhin das glück in konsum
von dingen suchen werden wir uns
weiterhin mit einem system zufrieden
geben dass uns nur reich fühlen lässt
während wir diese welt für unsere
nachkommen arm hinterlassen werden wir
weiterhin über jene leben einfach hin
wechseln die unsere kleidung erst
ermöglichen oder wird dies ein
wendepunkt sein ein neues kapitel in
unserer geschichte indem wir gemeinsam
eine wirkliche veränderung bewirken
indem wir uns bewusst machen dass alles
was wir tragen aus menschenhand
entstanden ist
inmitten all dieser herausforderungen
und all der probleme die uns vollkommen
ohnmächtig fühlen lassen könnten wir
vielleicht hier mit anfangen unserer
kleidung
[Musik]
ja
nein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schmecken
[Musik]
schön
im camp
[Musik]
nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]